[Music]
hey you guys it's monday yeah we're
sitting here talking about whether or
not we gotta get go down the store and
get some celery i want some crab salad
god damn it i've had that big thing of
like
crab with a k yeah and you keep saying
i'm gonna make it we gotta go to the
store but we haven't been in the store i
need hoagie rolls too for it though so
we need celery and hoagie rolls yeah
we don't have any bread to put it on
right
we have everything else we have mayo
right yeah you got everything sour cream
seafood salad and cream cheese if you
wanna put cream cheese in it i know and
i don't care if people think it's gross
i love that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right so uh yeah this is this is a
good little flick we saw last night it's
called vampires this is well like 1970
but it's 74 74 74 vampires with y yeah
or juan pierce
1974 british
british lesbian skin flick
like although technically they were
bisexual yeah well they were they were
there they were they were
yeah
vamp sexual yeah if that [ __ ] was sexy
there's if it had blood in it they were
gonna bang it and then drink the blood
out of it which seems like good you know
equal opportunity yep
everyone's blood tastes the same whether
you're a boy or a girl or whatever a lot
of people a lot of cute british women in
it you know although i don't think
either of the vampires were british the
italian
german i think uh the blonde anulka i
think she was german because i think she
had been in like german playboy or
whatever like she was playmate of the
year in 1973. marianne morris i'm not
sure
i don't think she was british either
it's not it doesn't really matter
because the hammer movies were like that
too where they just kind of got whoever
was hottest it's an international they
didn't necessarily have to be british
yeah um and
and
all of the european movies did that
italian movies had german actresses and
british actors in them too they just
worked wherever the work was
yeah and uh but this is a
cool little flick by today's standards
it's just what you'd call kind of like a
skin flick back in the days this this
would have been borderline x-rated
probably
uh yeah you it would have soft core porn
well it definitely is softcore porn yeah
i mean there's a lot of blood in it too
this was a lot gory or like more violent
than i remembered
um because i mostly just remembered the
boobs right you know it's just so many
boobs see hammer hammer was all
boobalicious because they used bustiers
a lot and [ __ ] those things were
[ __ ] hiked up around the girls ears
and they were [ __ ] super pretty real
good sets good acting you know [ __ ]
you'd have peter cushing show up
so
that was the route that a hammer flick
would go all right they did they
promised to show a lot they never really
would show
stuff it was just suggested this this
made up for all that
class that would normally be
a class
this movie had to make up for all that
that lack of class like like uh like
like hammerhead and they made it up with
it for just skid they were gonna show
you boobs they would show you girls
[ __ ] rolling around trying to have
oral sex with one another and [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] bite each other a
little bit of bush too yeah bush yeah
and a little bit of male nudity just
very very briefly yeah well they do the
market yeah there weren't going to be
any many guys to see this you know if
you weren't going to be it's like no one
wants to see pain this is going to be
mostly guys seeing this
and uh
it was good man the [ __ ] they have
like you know
stereotypical tropes they got the kind
of hot but nerdy straight girl and then
the lesbian vampire team are going to
try to [ __ ] swing them over this side
and they end up [ __ ] cutting her head
off and [ __ ] [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ]
happens it's it's uh
sadistic too
it's pretty sweet yeah it's interesting
because
like i said this actually i saw this a
long time ago uh this was actually
directed by jose ramon loraz who is he
spanish or i'm not i thought he was a
spanish director he also he also made a
movie called the violation of the [ __ ]
and you know yeah and you know that i'm
going to have to see that yeah you know
that's just that's just how it goes you
know but uh but yeah so i had seen this
a long time ago and i remember liking it
but i remember it not really having a
plot but it actually has like more of a
plot to it than i remembered oh it's not
like a lot of plot it's a lot of plot um
you know because it's just kind of a lot
of it doesn't really make any sense
because a lot of it's just kind of
engineered towards showing as much skin
and as much blood as possible
but it does have like things happen i
don't know why it's like for some reason
when i thought about this movie i'm like
oh it's just this the one with like the
two vampire ladies and they're just like
wandering around in this churchyard but
this does have that but i had forgotten
like about all the other stuff that
happened which i don't know why why
we're also talking about twins of evil
yeah we did that one count is dracula
yeah we did that one too
yeah yeah we might have done countless
tracks the one that was about uh
elizabeth so far i think my the best one
was stuck in um carmel carmilla that was
really the best one
i mean i kind of feel like lesbian or
bisexual vampires is like a very is a
pretty big sub genre yeah when you just
like you kind of think about
there's so many of them that i confuse
them with one another because carmilla
was
mostly just suggestion
there was nudity in it but most of it
was just suggested and situational [ __ ]
and uh of course all the girls were
[ __ ] smoking hot pretty in that one
these were good looking too but i would
say the ones that the ones out of
carmilla were better looking
yeah when you
yeah kind of hard to say though i don't
know a lot of people's makeup and
costumes yeah
i mean this one basically more just
[ __ ] down and dirty yeah and this one
like
literally like jumps right into it it's
just kind of like hey here's the movie
oh by the way here's two ladies having
sex enjoy yeah uh so you know what i
mean this one
just jumps right into it in its day this
would have been considered softcore porn
virgin v verging on x
i think in some countries it might have
been really yeah virginia
no real things people people don't
realize that there's a difference
between if you couldn't get an r rating
it was just x
yeah that's what they called it now if
it was just like porn that was triple x
but x was close it was what we would
call soft core
you know
didn't really show sex it just suggested
yeah
but like i said this does actually have
another nudity there's too much nudity
it became x because you weren't going to
be able to get an r rating
which seems weird because you'd think
that like the more nudity there was
you'd have like diminishing returns
because it's like okay yeah saying it
you
it's like i don't know it's just
quantity not quality i don't know it's
just like a whole it was the thinking of
the sensors of the day i guess so
but yeah this um and also they were
using
people were making these movies
exploiting the censorship of the day
trying to take a very low budget movie
and make it sensational so people would
see it like they were going to see
something well it was x we're going to
see some [ __ ] but then you said no it
wasn't really anything to look it wasn't
really a big deal
maybe it was to them but although i kind
of feel like if you went and saw this in
1974 i i feel like you'd feel like you
got your money's worth yeah in 74 in
1974 like not nowadays but right but
yeah so so the story behind this one
like i said this actually has more plot
than i had remembered it having
so you got these two vampires
um fran and miriam now i'm not entirely
sure this is like not really explained
yeah i think it's kind of like [ __ ] the
story i was just watching yeah it's not
important it's not important it's tough
for you well something that confused me
was that like literally the very first
scene of this movie is like this english
manor house which i'm looking at the
outside of the house going i know i've
seen some other movies that had that
house in it um which i think it was in
some hammer movies at first i thought it
was the same house from legend of hell
house but i don't think it is um but
yeah so i think it was like in a bunch
of hammer movies as well because it
looked real familiar but so the
literally the first scene is these two
chicks having sex in
their bed like in the manor house which
you're presuming is their manor house
some shadowy figure who is never
identified comes in and shoots them both
dead
and then there's credits and then
suddenly they're both like hitchhiking
out on an english country road and
suddenly they're vampires so i don't
really know how them getting shot
because i don't know they say at the end
that everybody you know oh nobody wants
to buy this house because nobody thinks
that it's haunted by these two women
that were murdered in there but it's
just like so were they supposed to be
ghosts
it didn't make any sense i didn't really
think much about it because that's well
that's kind of my i overthink this now
what this movie was about
was about boobs and stabbings
it was just really just about sex boobs
and stabbing the movie
it
it's a well-shot movie it looks good
it's got good-looking actresses in it
the storytelling is not the strong point
it's just a bunch of sex with some
murder scenes and people's heads get
ripped off and people drinking blood and
then it goes on to the next one uh uh
you don't i was not even trying to
follow it because
it was almost kind of like an italian
edit
where it didn't make sense but it's like
yeah it makes sense that this is spanish
yeah well i think the director is
spanish it was made in the uk but it's
kind of and i guess it was like a
british production company yeah but it's
got spanish fingerprints all over it you
have spanish yeah because you know they
were they were doing the same kind of
[ __ ] the italians were doing where film
was just art it was just a just an
experience you'd paid
some money to see it you weren't really
supposed to analyze it you weren't
supposed to read much into it they
didn't give a [ __ ] about plot or
continuity that much it's just just here
watch this wasn't that cool okay
watch this one look at all the jiggling
boobies yeah yeah it wasn't that so it
was just that's what they did and
everyone's like oh yeah let's post up
and if you see you know documentaries of
the [ __ ]
the italian directing style they're
going for one thing but they can't shoot
this okay well we'll just do this then
oh we can't we'll just do this then yeah
okay that's that's what they're doing
people they'll figure it out yeah yeah
yeah it won't matter it's a great film
great film
that's what they're doing
i don't care
they don't care i don't care
i don't care either but it's like like i
said i'm a storyteller so i was always
kind of like interested in it so for
some reason like these two uh women
getting shot like leads to them becoming
vampires so basically they're lurking
outside of what was presumably their
manor house at some time in the past i
don't know how much how long it's been
since that because it looks like it's a
little bit dilapidated but they what
they do is they'll go out
on the side of this country road and
then they'll hitchhike and then whatever
dude happens by you know it's like hey
can you give me a ride to my house it's
not that far and every dude is just kind
of like well sure get on in you know so
they get in and then they drive them
back to the house like hey how about you
come inside for some wine and you know
maybe something else
and all every single guy is just like
okay fair enough so they all kind of go
in there and then they all get uh
horribly killed and they drink their
blood but um and then what they do is
they take the bodies and then put them
back in the car so they don't show them
doing this but you're presumed that this
is what they do then they put the body
back in the car and then they turn the
car over out on the road so i'm always
like wondering so the whole time i'm
wondering like are the cops like man
there really are a lot of one car
accidents on this road what the [ __ ] is
going on but yeah so the main guy
our main male character uh ted now he's
presumably a businessman and the first
time you see him he shows up at like a
hotel i didn't really get why this scene
was in there either but it's like he
shows up this hotel
and wants to check and i don't know if
he's like in the first some conference i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but then
they make it like kind of a big deal
about this old man that works at the
hotel like saying haven't i seen you
somewhere before ted's being like no no
no so i thought that there was going to
be something tying in with like he was
the dude that shot the women or he
was like
i don't know no no what happened was
just that they were trying to tell a
story but budget budget but then they
forgot yeah
or something happened somebody didn't
show up so they got to knock this [ __ ]
out so just
make just continue
ladies kill more people
yeah we just forgot everything we said
at the beginning there are people in
there talking about you know movies of
the era like midnight cowboy and [ __ ]
um what was the other one that they were
talking about easy riders they didn't
even really care much for those
those were actually okay movies but you
have to understand those are those are
boomer movies
they they spoke to the boomer generation
for some strange reason i don't really
understand a lot of the things that they
had held up as
cultural milestones
uh those two movies were just kind of
like okay they're okay movies but th
this movie is kind of like an italian
boomer art flick and and they got away
with a lot of [ __ ] back then they had to
make movies they had to make movies
quickly and cheaply you're in the middle
of a damn project something doesn't go
right so well okay we can't do that
let's just do this and just [ __ ] the
script more blood more yeah they had a
lot of times they had a script but as
long as it's 85 minutes halfway through
it they're like well we can't do this
because such and such [ __ ] the script
we'll just do this instead it'll all
work out don't worry about it and then
they try to edit it all together it
doesn't really work out but then they
just look at it goes oh this is a
marvelous film
this is a marvelous film okay yeah send
it out
it'll make money and and they would show
this [ __ ] in a theater it would make me
as long as the poster looked good and
they brought and like i said if you're
paying a lot of like teenage boys are
paying to see these movies and as long
as there was like you know tits and some
muffins and things twice three times
yeah they'll be like all right yeah
that would match you looking great and
they didn't even notice the story
i just but what i thought was
interesting though was that some of the
scenes at the beginning like with them
getting shot for example which is like
the first scene and then the scene of
ted the businessman
at the hotel
like checking into a room and then that
old guy like haven't i seen you
somewhere before and like they were kind
of making a big deal about it so it
almost seemed like they were trying to
set up a story but then they didn't like
do anything with that i don't think
unless i was like not paying attention
and then there were movies where it kind
of felt like they were [ __ ] up but in
the end it all turned out great like
like roman polanski's the tenant it
seemed like he was [ __ ] up but no
everything in there means something
yeah um
so sometimes it was hard to tell because
they kind of had that
boomer art flick tone
to them whether they were good or bad
they kind of had that tone
yeah
this is just a bad one well the thing
about this though but this is still
entertaining though yeah well it's it's
doing what it's supposed to do yeah
and so lesbian vampires lots of boobs
pretty girls
and this was and it's supposed to be
scary and there's some [ __ ] bunch of
bloody scenes in it um you're not
supposed to worry about continuity they
kind of [ __ ] up that part up i think
probably yeah print it and this is pre
internet porn pre vhs pre anything
this is for young guys this is the only
time they're gonna be able to see
[ __ ] high quality boobs like this
maybe at least leave some high quality
yeah on [ __ ] film well yeah you want
some that are moving they're moving and
[ __ ] they're getting photographs but
they're like oh okay yeah yeah just
shaking the picture isn't really like
it's not really the same and that was a
track that was an attraction enough in
this era
this movie could have been fixed you
could have done a lot but they just did
i don't think they had time or the money
and like i said this is still an
entertaining movie i find this
entertaining it's like it's really like
atmospheric and stuff i'm just
fascinated by it because they did
actually try to like there's characters
in there and there doesn't like okay so
so ted after he goes like to the hotel
he picks up fran like one of the
hitchhikers she takes him back to the
manor house and then there's kind of
like a long thing where she drinks blood
they don't have fangs though which i
guess like saved a lot of money because
they didn't have to make dental
appliances for everybody they just like
cut open yeah your arm and just like
drink out of your arm kind of like a
hunger yeah it's kind of like the hunger
where they don't have fangs in that
movie either but uh yeah so it's kind of
that kind of thing but then for whatever
reason like the later dudes that they
pick up um you know that that the other
the miriam also the the blonde that she
picks up too
and they usually just bring the dudes
back and just like just chop them up and
like drink them and then you know chuck
them in the [ __ ] you know car
accident or whatever but for whatever
reason
fran seems to have like taken some kind
of liking to ted it's like she's still
drinking out of him but
she's kind of like saving that [ __ ] you
know what i mean so it's kind of like
she doesn't kill him right away she just
like keeps and i guess he
is sort of like falling under her spell
because he wakes up the next morning
he's like oh dude i don't feel so good
it's like oh i must have cut myself on
the wine glass or whatever and he's like
kind of hung over an anemic or whatever
and then he can't find her and then
so he's gonna leave but then he comes
back so it's almost like she has some
kind of like psychic hold on him said
you forgot about the two the two campers
well i was just gonna yeah i was gonna
get to that too because like i said i
was trying to talk about it and then you
kept saying like i don't want to like
forget yeah it's my fault but it is
this piece of [ __ ] movie we're not
worried about too much about this piece
of [ __ ]
like i said everybody everybody was
excited that i was doing all vampire
movies this week but yeah so there's two
campers also who um you know are just
randomly on a camping trip and they've
kind of like parked their little
little what you call it outs on the
grounds of this thing and you know
they're doing fishing and all that other
kind of crap and like the first night
when ted comes out and like doesn't know
that he's just been like vampired um you
know he's just like oh look i cut myself
and they help him out and everything but
for whatever reason like the girl camper
is super interested in like what the
[ __ ] going on at the house i thought
it was abandoned and then she sees a
light up there and so at one point she
goes in there and kind of breaks in now
see i thought that and it's like funny
because her boyfriend is just like what
is it no there's nothing weird it's just
there's one scene where
she wakes up in the middle of the night
because she hears a dude scream which
she totally did because you know the the
vampire ladies like picked somebody up
and they're like killing him in there so
he was screaming about it so she wakes
up in the camper because she heard
somebody scream and then like there's
like a hand like
hits against the window of the camper
and she wakes up her boyfriend it's like
hey man like somebody's out there
there's like a hand and everything and
he's like he does like the total dude
things like every movie in the 70s and
every episode of haunting you imagined
it yeah yeah i imagined a dude screaming
in a person's hand like banging against
yeah i totally imagine that's just
hallucinating
because i was almost i knew he was going
to do that i was like wait for it wait
for it yeah that's what i thought oh you
just are you sure you weren't dreaming
yeah you know how girls do how they
don't know like how every how [ __ ]
brains work they're just sitting here
and they see some [ __ ]
i see that in a movie it just makes me
laugh
you know how it is and i just knew i
could tell like by the look on his face
that he was gonna say
that it's your imagination that's like
exactly what he's saying they don't see
[ __ ] that's there and then they see [ __ ]
that isn't there you know how it is they
don't know how they don't know anything
so we don't even know if something's
there i don't even know if this laptop
is here i don't even know if you're not
no i'm not here it's all in your mind
yeah that sounds like that sounds like
some [ __ ] you would say it's funny
what's funny though is that they did
that choke over and over again in movies
over and over and over again i mean oh
she doesn't know she's talking about
that's why that's what well that's why i
laughed and it's like that's why i
laughed when he went that way because
i'm just like wait for it wait for it
he's gonna say where did that come from
i don't know i think it's just an
unnecessarily complication i wanna write
you know what it doesn't cost any money
to do it so they do it i guess i want to
write now now i'm kind of interested now
i want to write a book
about that trope in movies and like
where it came from like like what was
the first iteration of that it's got to
be super old yeah because i feel like
that was probably even in like silence
it probably went back to the eighteen
hundreds of women fainting
yeah it's gotta it's gotta be super old
yeah well because i kind of feel like
for even in literature and kind of ever
well just in life in general like
particularly back then in the victorian
era probably prior to that um it was
kind of thing was like oh women they you
know they have hysteria with that womb
that wanders around which actually is
what we're going to do the show about
their [ __ ] water runner
[Laughter]
he's got a spiritual [ __ ] that wasn't
water i know man it's like i can't i
can't count the number of times that
i've woken up and i give up my womb has
escaped and it was like walking around
the neighborhood and i had to like go
drive the car and like find out where
she went ghost [ __ ] that's the problem
little womb wandering down the street
i'm out of here i'm going to 7-eleven
for some smokes yeah i don't know what
the [ __ ] they're talking about
i think
i think what it was it's so funny to me
the whole fainting victorian woman thing
they used to say well it's because of
the courses i don't believe so i think
it was virtue signaling
it was to show everyone else that they
were shocked i think that's what it was
although the courses probably didn't
help
gotta be fair
i can't breathe i've never [ __ ] my
friend melissa corseted herself down to
like a [ __ ] waist about that big so
it was super easy and it didn't it
didn't bother her she had to back off
though because it was she was starting
to suffer but yeah
rearrange your organs yeah because you
know you only got so much room in there
like [ __ ] that she wore it all the
time she said it just got easier and
easier you could tighten it up it always
felt loose yeah and then she just got
she crushed her little rib cage in and
[ __ ] like that but she you know she was
that's the way she liked that you know
yeah um
and she said she never had any kind of
fainting spells
it's just that she could tell something
was wrong
yeah i don't i don't think i mean when i
have the corset on it it's like really
tight or something it's not so much i
feel like i'm gonna faint it's more like
i feel like i'm gonna throw up yeah
because like if you try to eat with it
it feels like the food can't go all the
way down your esophagus it feels like
she said she didn't eat much yeah she
said you could get away with eating very
little
after a while yeah um but
but i think what it was was they were
just showing off to everybody else that
something had happened and that they
were overwhelmed
yeah because they are deity yeah yeah
that's probably what it was you know
what i mean oh my god i can't oh i can't
take my virgin sensibility yeah yeah my
sense of my sensibilities are
overwhelmed i can't take it
save me well yeah because it's kind of
like well because if you were a lady
back then and like something gross
happened and you were like awesome like
everybody would like be like which it
was a way it was it was a way of getting
approval of being dainty and genteel
louis said the first time i saw this
movie as a kid i thought ingrid pitt
played fran well ingrid pitt
played she was in countess dracula
wasn't she like the hammer one was that
i'm pretty sure we did that yeah so that
might be what you were thinking of uh
yeah mike barrett points out and i was
gonna say this they did a remake of this
film yeah i think it was 2014 2015 or
something like that
i was gonna watch it because i think
it's for free on tubey which this one is
as well although it's also on shutter
that's what we watched it on shutter but
um i was like yeah i really don't think
we need to see a remake of this because
i'm sure it's probably not very good
because honestly it's like like i said
this doesn't have what they were gonna
do where i was going with like the
female camper thing they seemed to be
setting up
because as soon as she arrived she's
like who are those two ladies and
they're like acting really weird and
there's somebody in that house and you
know all this other so she seemed like
really interested in what was going on
over there so i thought that again that
they were setting up that the two
vampire ladies were gonna like take her
in like hey sister like they were gonna
kill all the dudes
and then
you know let's make her like our vampire
third it you know
um so i thought that's where it was
going but that's totally not what they
did with it they just killed her
you know but i don't even think they i
don't even think they drank her blood
did they i think they just like well
they took all her clothes off i don't
even remember and then cut her through
and then they were just like man they
cut her head off or something didn't it
or they cut her throat i don't know if
they cut her whole head off yeah they
didn't do anything with her i thought
they were gonna turn into a vampire see
i thought that too because i thought
they they spent so much time like
building up the character and then there
was that scene
see that's what i mean there's like all
these scenes in there that i thought
were going somewhere and they didn't
like go anywhere so there's that there
was i think it was going to go somewhere
well that's what i mean that's but but
i'm interested to know because there's
one scene where the lady camper
is um lady camper she is uh painting the
manor house like she would she's got her
canvas and her and everything like
painting a picture of it she's not
actually painting it so she's painting a
picture of it and then the two vampires
like come out of the woods like she's
just like ooh what the [ __ ] and like she
thinks somebody's back there and then
the two vampire ladies come out of the
woods and then they say something like
um
you know fran says something about like
you know i'll i can recognize you like
my mark now or something like that and
she does a thing with her thumb on her
forehead yeah and you know later they
show the lady camper like look in the
mirror and go what the [ __ ] why did she
touch my head what does that mean so i
thought that they that they were leading
up to hey you're our next like vampire
conquest we're going to make you a
vampire and then we'll be like a vampire
lady gang and we're going to go around
like well i think that's what it was
supposed to be see that would have been
awesome i think it was supposed to be
that but something happened behind the
scenes to production they couldn't maybe
she had to leave the project maybe they
didn't like her or something like that
she was a shakespearean stage actress
the one the one that played the lady
camper maybe she quit so he says okay
we're gonna get your role done [ __ ]
the next couple days so you can get out
of here something like that she did say
that her and the director didn't get
along yeah although she said that the
director was kind of mean to her and was
mean to the guy that was playing her
boyfriend okay so he might probably
something like that so maybe that so
they just changed the script to get rid
of her and uh then you know they would
[ __ ]
uh um
then they would make an excuse oh well
we meant to do that all along we were
just um what do you call it we're a
[ __ ] um
there's a term that they use now when
you're expecting one thing but then it
doesn't
that's not how
it's not how the story uh is going to go
something about your expectations
[ __ ] we're subverting what's that
subverting your expectations no that's
not what you did you just [ __ ] [ __ ]
the story up because you kicked them
you kicked that [ __ ] actress off you
never didn't intend to do that yeah
subverting expectations
that's just that's just that's just how
you
take your errors and your fuck-ups and
spin it around to
try to convince the the audience that uh
or your customers
that you're artistic
you didn't like it because you did
couldn't appreciate the artistic
qualities of this film it subverted your
expectations
so in other words it wasn't as good as
you thought it was going to be
that's surprising expectations
it's [ __ ] funny although like i said
i don't think this is like uh
no nobody ever said that because this
was just kind of like a cheap cash grab
but yeah but it's i just thought it was
interesting because they did really
not this movie i'm saying in movies in
general that directors and [ __ ] do that
they did actually really seem to be set
like taking great pains to like set up
plot points yeah like i said yeah with
with say for example ted checking at the
hotel the guy saying hey haven't i seen
you before and the guy being like no no
you don't know who i am i'm just like
i've never been here before so i thought
they were gonna set up like he was a
reincarnation of somebody or other um so
i thought there was that whole thing the
whole thing of like fran keeping him
alive even though they just pretty much
immediately killed the other ones and
the whole thing was like the lady camper
like with the thing with the mark on the
forehead and her being like super
fascinated so i kind of thought that
that that all of those were kind of
gonna lead to something they did
yeah so
but it's just it that was i don't know
that was just like really interesting to
me like i said it's not a bad movie it's
like it's kind of a cool like stylish
like atmospheric kind of thing but it
does kind of feel like they set up a lot
of plot points that don't really go any
place they were gonna go somewhere but
something happened in production and
they just
they stopped following the script or
couldn't follow the script so they had
to find alternate ways to end the movie
and to shoot the movie that's what
happens oh plus can i give a shout out
to like the dude playing the
mansplaining wine uh expert i don't know
i liked it oh yeah yeah but he was like
the last i think he was the last dude
that they killed
like they brought him in like for the
party and he was just they brought him
down to the wine cellar and he's like oh
this is a this and this is a bat and
then it's like
then he thought he was gonna drop his
nuts by saying because they gave him
some wine and uh he was like i'm gonna
guess where this is from and friends
like you're never gonna guess i was like
did they make it from their menstrual
blood that was first thing i thought of
but no that wasn't the answer but um but
yeah so so he tried to be like all
clever and [ __ ] like that and she was
like ah wrong but i mean to his credit
at least he didn't go no oh you're wrong
which i kind of felt like he probably
would have but he was just kind of like
oh okay my bad i think originally
i think originally the movie probably
had a good script but they couldn't
follow the script for one
reason or another and you ended up with
with kind of like a typical southern
european kind of movie
where you stop following the script
halfway through it you know like like
you do it like what happened what would
happen in italy and in spain that's what
they would do maybe
all the wine bottles in that cellar were
real and they were full of really good
wine and all of the crew were just so
[ __ ] hammered that they couldn't even
remember
like halfway through the movie like they
just went through the whole cellar i'm
just making stuff up um but they just
went through the whole cellar and then
there's like they don't even know where
the script is they spilled wine all over
it they couldn't read it anymore it was
all smudged so they were basically just
they basically just wrote in more
stabbing than boobies the end
[Laughter]
well because then at the very end they
have like this old couple
who are supposed to be american and one
of them sounds american but the other
one still sounds british but um they
came there like to buy the house and
like the real estate agent is like
telling them yeah this has been
abandoned for a long time because
supposed to be haunted by these two
women but see after the two vampire
ladies like kill the camper lady
they were just like yeah we gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here i guess like
killing all the dudes like no one gave a
[ __ ] and like no one noticed but the
second like they killed the camper lady
they were like oh [ __ ] we gotta go so
they took off like across you know and
vanished into the sunset and
so i don't so i don't know if they were
just supposed to be because they're
clearly vampires right because they were
drinking blood they don't have any you
know they don't have any fangs or
nothing but but then they were kind of
also trying to imply that they were
ghosts because they got shot at the
beginning yeah well
you're trying to make sense i'm thinking
about this more than anybody that made
this movie ever thought about it
[Laughter]
pat said from what he heard the uh the
director was asked that's that's i heard
that too i heard that too although that
said i still want to see his other movie
the violation of the [ __ ] because
that's one of the best movie titles of
all time
well he's sitting back
you must understand something there's
all these [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm constantly thinking about [ __ ]
being violated
i'm going to make a new movie
called the violation of the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
because i think about it
think about these [ __ ] and think
about the violation
gonna have to violate some [ __ ]
or at least one how does one violate
[ __ ]
then he comes out with a [ __ ] script
that's that's what he [ __ ] think
i'm going to violate some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's what you think
i imagine there's probably like whips
and yeah and whips and chains involved
there's like hot british actresses and
[ __ ] going who is this [ __ ]
guy's an [ __ ]
pass me that joint
you're an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're a tosser
tosser
yeah oh you [ __ ] pillock you [ __ ]
something yeah he's real overweight you
[ __ ] i kind of feel like wanker he's
probably they'd probably call him a
wagon yeah
thomas channel like dino de laurentiis
yeah yeah
oh yeah we'll make a move we're going to
make a movie yeah mike barrett said i
listened to the commentary on the dvd
from the director and he didn't sound
like he had problems with the film maybe
this is the way he intended i know but
it really does seem very
that
strange
just protecting his work
it does seem straight although i will
say and i don't know if it's just
something that's i don't know what it is
because i kind of feel like there's
um you know some italian movies that are
like this as well
where
a lot of stuff seems like it's going to
lead to something like i said where they
kind of seem like they do these scenes
where they're like ooh significant we're
setting this thing up but then they
never do anything with it just watch the
just what just watch uh interviews of
the directors of [ __ ] troll 2. and
the [ __ ] how troll two was made and
that's very typical that's a typical
italian that dude totally still thinks
that's a good movie i think that's what
you're dealing with
[Laughter]
which was kind of like the typical
italian workmen like [ __ ] let's knock
this [ __ ] out you know let's get it
done that's that's what they're doing
which in a way kind of reminds me of
that scene in tim burton's ed woods yeah
yeah where you know people were like
knocking over the cardboard gravestones
he's like no one's gonna notice it's
like everybody get out of me that's what
they're doing even though literally
everybody knows and then afterwards they
cook up a whole story about how artistic
it is and oh no this is this is intended
this way
yeah yeah it's just just to defend the
work the integrity of the work no
they're full of [ __ ] man
they made that up as they were going
along the the the script probably was
pretty good
but
they talk about it over and over again
they get into positions where they can't
follow the script anymore because
somebody doesn't show up or they run out
of money or usually they run out of
money they spend too much money so they
can't do that anymore they have to
[ __ ] have to fire people because they
can't afford them now and all kinds of
weird [ __ ] happens behind the scenes
which totally [ __ ] the movie up that's
what like saturn three uh really one of
my favorite side five movie was [ __ ]
harvey keitel and fair fawcett and
[ __ ] old was his name and the damn
robot they're supposed to be kind of
like alien
that was to be a really good movie now
it's only like half a good movie
it didn't have an ending because they
couldn't afford to shoot anymore so they
had to [ __ ] change a bunch of [ __ ]
around
and they had to get really cheap [ __ ]
space [ __ ] scenes from japan like
touhou did the [ __ ] space scenes all
those [ __ ] cheesy looking [ __ ]
well and the thing about it is it was
almost good especially would have been
better had it had they actually been
able to [ __ ] execute the script
especially kind of with
you know maybe a little bit lower budget
or smaller production company stuff like
that they're not real good like you read
a script
and unless you have like a bunch of you
know really on the ball people like
advising you
you're not entirely sure how much it's
going to cost to do that and like
sometimes i kind of feel like
maybe they lowball it a little bit
just so they can get the money to make
it but then like they end up shooting
all the stuff and it costs more than
they thought so they're like well [ __ ]
now we can't shoot this that the other
thing so like you said it might get to a
point where well we were gonna have like
this big [ __ ] space battle at the end
but now we can't do that so we're just
gonna
um have a kid waking up in bed and
saying it was all a dream yeah you know
what i mean that kind of [ __ ] see louie
called it before i didn't i just seen
his comment now he says the production
probably ran out of money and the film
went off the rails they probably blew
the funds on blow probably right correct
that's you i mean like i said this start
partying and they [ __ ] spend the
[ __ ] money on hookers and blow that's
what happens and then they go we gotta
finish it they don't have the money [ __ ]
and then um put some more boobs in there
have them stab in a couple more days
i have it on blu-ray and kirk douglas's
butt yeah he seems nude during most of
the shooting he said he got used to it
and he wouldn't put his clothes back on
and everyone's like god damn it kirk
yeah
he was in good
but i don't necessarily want to see some
old guy run around naked on the set all
the time when i'm at work you know what
i'm saying i have that movie on blu-ray
and it's it's actually the blu-rays
looks [ __ ] good looks really good um
too bad they they dubbed harvey keitel
it's not his voice yeah that was that he
didn't want a new york accent yeah
because he had a new york but over
overall it does [ __ ] come that's a
really cool character that he does
there's a lot of good in that movie
there was a lot of potential
um it was ahead of its time neuro links
cybernetics
um [ __ ] uh
having robots with [ __ ] human brains
cloned human brains in them and a big
fat
it [ __ ] learned off of you and
a robot [ __ ] becoming obsessed with a
woman because it's part human it's
[ __ ] it it was way ahead of its time
it's just that they ran out of money and
it
and
they had to cheap out on a bunch of
stuff which
blew the movie it didn't give it a good
strong ending
and the space cut scenes were pretty bad
looking
but all the interior shots were good the
acting was pretty good and
the story was pretty good it's just that
it didn't uh
it didn't have a good climax
the way the robot died should have been
about 20 minutes yeah it just fell
through a hole in the floor right yeah
it blew up type
they weren't able to do a lot of stuff
that the script asked for
but i recommend it i recommend it on
blu-ray if you can get it it's worth
getting and like i said i've i've kind
of heard you know just from reading the
backstories of a lot of different movies
even ones that actually um you know
turned out really good miraculously um a
lot of times like if you read like the
original script of them it's like
sometimes they had all this other [ __ ]
planned uh and they were just like well
when we got halfway through the
production you know the people were like
hey you know you're not getting any more
money and it's like you only have x
amount of dollars left so they're they
have to go through the script and like
well we need to cut this out we need to
cut this out we need to cut this out so
i don't know i don't know if this if
that affected this one like i said this
is still like an entertaining movie and
like i said it's definitely if you're
into the erotic horror you know erotic
vampire genre this is definitely way
more on
i mean
it is definitely way more on the
softcore porn side than it is on the
horror side um even though it is pretty
bloody and it does have like some pretty
gory like violent uh you know sequences
in it but i'm just i was intrigued
because
there were just so many scenes that you
know and it's very it's quite well acted
and it's quite well shot so it's like
it's you know it's competently made and
it's a pretty nice looking movie and the
sets are nice looking it's just i just
thought it was interesting that they
spent so much time building up these
little you know these little like
nuggets of plot that really didn't seem
to like
tie together or they didn't like seem to
go anywhere they had to do with a bunch
of stuff maybe that's what it was yeah
although i don't see why it would be
that expensive to shoot
hey we're gonna take this girl with us
rather than just killing her
it would have made sense if you were
there at the time it was something they
had to get rid of somebody or if i was
as high as they were at the time
and there was definitely you know they
were trying to do something else but
then they had to they had to wrap it up
karen asked did you find the key
no
weird we have no [ __ ] idea where that
key is i'm starting to think somehow it
might have accidentally thrown it away
i can't really think of anything else it
could because pookie could not have
eaten it that that was too big for her
to eat
she might have carried it somewhere
and dropped it but i you know in her
mouth but i don't i don't she wouldn't
have been able to like eat it because it
was too big i mean i'm trying to put
myself
i wasn't carrying anything when i came
back
so it's not like i had my key in my in
the hand
and garbage and then gone by a garbage
can
i wasn't in it wasn't doing that because
i've done that before yeah so i don't
know i had something in my head that had
garbage in my head like i had garbage
from the car or something i was just
like ah then i had to like dig in there
like get the [ __ ] out no i didn't have
anything i just jumped off the bike and
walked in the house and i've been taking
my motorcycle helmet off and i usually
leave the key in the ignition
there's no reason to take the key out so
you pulled up all the mats in the garage
and everything like that it's not is it
under the refrigerator in the garage
maybe
i can move that and see but i shown a
light underneath there didn't see
anything um
did you check the washer and dryer yeah
yeah and i've done like a couple of
laundry
your thing out just so i can see you
know the big [ __ ] spike that stirs
the clothes i took it out yeah it's just
on it with a bolt took it out there was
nothing there
yeah because i've done it and you know i
even washed your motorcycle pants i went
through all the pockets and with my uh
driver's license id and my title i can
go to i can go to harley-davidson and
based on the vin number they can cut me
a new key for about 35 so it's not that
bad that's what i mean that's like a lot
cheaper than i had to pay like 200 bucks
to get [ __ ] extra keys for my stupid
car yes i guess i'll just have to do
that
i mean i got the other bike i can ride
tammy says it's still on the bike no
that's where he would normally leave it
but
it wasn't in there wasn't in there he
either leaves it in the bike or on the
television on in front of the television
like on the tv or on the night stand
right on his side of the bat there's a
chance i could have gone into the
walk-in closet and put it on top of
something on on top of where the uh
you know the uh
where i keep the blue rays and then take
my armor off but it's not there yeah i
turned the closet upside down even went
through all the damn pants looking
through all the pockets it's just gone
poacher guys got it maybe it did
well in between these walls hey
poltergeist yeah bring the damn keys
bring the key back and that'd be a
[ __ ] trip we're sorry if the key fell
out of the ceiling and i thought whoa
we found it on top i was like waiting
for it to happen i found it on top of
the door or you leave the office and
it's sitting in front of it it's sitting
on the floor it's on top of the fan
blades or something of the [ __ ]
there's all kinds of weird [ __ ]
poltergeist yeah
so he's so tricksy yeah i don't know
where it is
yeah could someone have walked into your
garage and taken it no no you'd think
they'd have taken the whole bike if they
did that
yeah
i mean because what we always have to do
they would just most
where the key is
most people wouldn't even think that
there'd be a key there yeah on a view of
lightning the key is on the side of the
front [ __ ] bikini fairing going along
the side of the motorcycle above the
forks it's not on the top
so the average person can't even see
where the key is
keep going aside
it's not real obvious and we don't have
i mean we kind of live in like a gated
community so you don't really have a lot
of people walking around
and um you know and our garage is never
open you're right so gotta bribe pookie
and have her show you where she put it
[Laughter]
and the steering column is not locked
and the motorcycle is here which means
the key is here
yeah because you came back on it
wouldn't have the key it wouldn't be
here yeah yeah
so i don't know i had the key when i
showed up i don't know where it is come
on poltergeist give it back i'm just
we're sending you like little waves how
i could have thrown it away
i wouldn't have been wouldn't have been
carrying anything
yeah other than maybe my helmet
yeah
it's a mystery yeah it's a mystery for
the ages yeah
all right are we done yeah okay so
tomorrow we'll probably do another
vampire movie um
we'll either do
near dark which actually i want to do
because um
i think dj maniac yesterday said that
shutter was
taking it down at the end of august
because i guess they only had it for a
limited amount of time and i've been
wanting to do that for him for a long
time because i really love that movie
and a lot of people have like uh
requested it so it'll probably be near
dark although somebody has to stew vamp
as well which i think is on tubey
which i haven't seen that in a long time
with grace jones in it
i don't know so we'll see it'll it'll be
one of those two probably
so i guess that'll do it for our review
of the
smuddys muddy vampire movie vampires
with a y from 1974. and uh have a good
rest of your day everybody we will see
you again tomorrow afternoon bye